I hate to be saying this and I really
hope that I'm wrong but we may now be on
the precipice of the global recession
that we anticipated would eventually
come we didn't know when but one of the
inherent elements of our system is the
persistent booms and busts there's
always some downturn some recession
around the corner we just don't know how
many blocks we are from turning the
corner so to speak right now the stock
market is open as we are producing
today's show just 9 minutes in the stock
market dropped by so much in the United
States that it triggered some protective
measures which shut down trading
immediately in the United States
ten minutes later stocks reopened at
9:50 a.m. Eastern Time and the stocks
have been up and down all day today
could be could be the greatest single
day decline in stock market history on a
points basis not on a percentage basis
it may reverse before the end of the day
we don't know but as of right now we
could have the largest one-day point
decline in the history of our stock
market in addition to this the oil
market has crashed oil prices fell as
much as 34% and stabilized down about
21% again as of right now this
information may change by the time you
listen to today's show or watch this
clip Saudi Arabia and Russia are now in
a growing price war this is the most
that oil prices have fallen in decades
then they stabilize down about 21% and
those numbers will continue to change
over the weekend Russia refused to say
how much oil they are producing they
were asked to make some commitments in
order to stabilize the market Russia
refused to say how much oil they're
producing Saudi Arabia in response then
drastically cut prices this caused world
markets to crash the UK footsie 100
index was down 7% as of a couple hours
ago American stock markets also down and
then of course on top of all of this we
have the growing virus situation which
we have been covering extensively and
will cover later on today and I know you
all know about as well so listen we may
be at the start of a mass
of global recession which if indeed is
starting now it could be years before we
get back to the price levels of the
stock market of a month ago now the
stock market doesn't affect everybody at
least not directly and to be clear I
hope it doesn't happen every time I
tweet about the economy I get tweets
from followers who say Oh David you're
just begging for an economic crash so
that Donald Trump gets politically hurt
aren't you no I'm not I've made that
clear I don't want people losing their
jobs
I don't want stocks crashing I don't
want anyone to die from the virus I'm
not a terrible person so I don't want
horrible things to happen just so that
people realize that Donald Trump is an
incompetent buffoon and to be frank if
you've not already realized Donald Trump
is an incompetent buffoon the stock
market crashing or the virus spreading
or whatever else is not going to
convince those people it would be a
futile effort if that's what I'm
counting on it would be both morally
wrong and misguided based on the facts
what I want to focus on is look at how
quickly things can go into the trash in
a period of 7 to 8 weeks if there is any
bigger picture message here it's that of
the inherent fragility of our system
this is partially about the inherent
nature of the economic system we have it
is fragile we've learned food supply
lines are more fragile than we think
markets are more fragile than we think
the medical system is fragile it quickly
becomes overwhelmed when something like
the virus starts to spread ventilators
are at are in short supply hospital beds
are in short supply panicked people buy
masks they don't even need causing a
shortage for health care workers who
actually do need them for as long as our
economic system remains fundamentally
what it is now this fragility will
always exist and in fact the booms and
the busts are part of the system we've
been talking about this for years as far
as the micro what's the stock market
doing today what is the response of our
completely misguided and ignorant
administration in terms of the virus we
will see how that shakes out today we
will
see how it shakes out tomorrow if indeed
this is the start of a global recession
once again it could be years before we
get back to the point where we were just
2 months ago but for as long as our
economic system remains fundamentally
what it is right now these fragile sort
of awakenings the awakening of the
fragility of the system will keep
cropping up because the system is
fragile that's the reality that's not
advocating for prepping that's not
advocating for communism it's the
reality of the version of the capitalist
system that we have and of so many other
things that we've been talking about as
well